welcome to the 14th ever episode of the
iced coffee hour
what's new how much money have we made
so far we have made
2 68 and 90 cents
yeah so that is an average of 42.51
cents per day
in the past 28 days wow cool so we're
actually it's good yeah this is like
this is like a full-time career now no
kidding really it is
not bad at all and that's counting
weekends as well yeah saturday and
sunday
so nice yeah very cool so thank you guys
so much for all of the support i really
appreciate it this is the first episode
by the way that we're filming in the
morning
yeah we always film these at nights um
but yeah
early in the morning it's thursday
morning 8 30 7 a.m
yeah if i seem tired this is this is why
but we do have iced coffee
and we usually both don't drink iced
coffee because we usually film at like
10 p.m or something ridiculous
but now we have it i sip i sip on it
start it right off uh youtube commented
on one of our videos
i know insane i still don't believe
that's real
yeah so yeah youtube's youtube account
has like 30 million subscribers verified
and everything they commented on
our david dobrik video yeah so what are
we gonna do
so i have a thought when it comes to
that i am convinced
it has to be someone at youtube watching
who didn't realize you're logged in the
account
it has to be because i don't believe
that youtube would just be like just out
there
commenting on channels maybe
but then why would someone be watching
the videos from the youtube account
how many people have access to that
account yeah
no it it threw me off as well and when i
saw it i
i was so flustered yeah and then i i
told you
and our conversation was actually quite
funny i'll throw up screenshots if it's
okay available
but but yeah like i saw and then you
said you thought
that someone forgot to log out or
something i thought and i i really that
never occurred to me and i thought that
was such a far-fetched
like conclusion or or like for some
reason i i just didn't think that was
the case
and then people were responding to the
youtube comments saying that
so maybe that was the case but you know
what the weird thing is they used my
name
they said graham make sure to smash the
like button for
graham uh subscriber wouldn't say that
sounds like a youtube-esque thing to do
yes yeah because then it's like
they're talking about a person like any
subscriber would be like yeah just smash
the like button for the algorithm or
something
yeah but no one ever comments like
graham
so that kind of makes me think it is
actually youtube
it's just weird the whole thing is weird
it's in a good way like in a really
amazing really good way yeah we were
freaking out
made my uh made my whole week really
yeah imagine if they commented on this
that would be crazy if they're watching
watching everything they're like
that's like for the youtube algorithm
graham that would be like mildly
unsettling
like if they were watching everything
you know what i mean it's like how far
can they go you know
like you're older they show them outside
of the house yeah someone just peering
in through the bushes
he's like hey what's up how's it going
they're always watching
i wouldn't mind it's okay also for an
update
uh on the options trading i am so far
eight
for eight in auction stream
you're gonna get to 19.
of course i will tell them about our uh
our bet here right right so
it's 20. uh 20 options trades if i'm 20
for 20 in the green
then graham will he'll say he's proud he
didn't even say that much
he would be impressed okay so right now
you're eight well
i'm actually seven for seven my eighth
contract is open right now but i'm so
far in the green on my eighth contract
okay so and the total return so far is
what
it's about 5.7 or so percent
all right that's not bad you would have
been higher had you just bought neo
and held yeah but i i that's that's a
hypothetical
right it's like i had so much control
over
my gains and losses and this type of
option trading selling puts but
that's not too bad and uh explaining my
my
poor returns obviously off of eight
trades you know 5.7
isn't that great this is because i make
very very conservative trades in options
trading to lower risk
all right so if you get a million
dollars you'd be up 50 grand
yeah yeah i'd be up around 50 grand so
if you were to loan me a million dollars
and i were to invest it
you could be all right so i'll loan you
money at a seven percent interest rate
you'd have to make at least seven seven
percent per year
million dollars seven percent so 70 000
a year i couldn't
in my right mind i could never invest a
million dollars in options trading i
would just be way too scared
and also one thing that graham and i
have been for some reason we've just
been we haven't done it because it it
takes us getting ready and stuff
is changing the profile picture in the
name of the channel or whatever
yeah like i personally just to let you
guys know i it does
it doesn't bother me whatsoever that i'm
not in the middle it bothers like two
people
yeah they're like visibly bob or
whatever and someone else i i know you
guys really want me in the in the
profile picture
i'm saying it right now that we're gonna
do it that means we have to do it by
sunday
all right so so we're going to do it
between now and sunday this is going to
hold us accountable
all right we'll make it out it's going
to happen also add us on instagram
stefan jels selby jack
yeah you guys all already have graham
add me on instagram
one thing i think would be really cool
is a q a segment so if you guys want to
comment questions as well
we'll answer them two episodes from now
because we have a very very exciting
guest for next week yeah
you know what or they could ask
questions now
for us to ask the mystery guest next
next week you don't know who it is
but ask questions you want someone to
answer
some something you want someone to
answer could be us could be our mystery
guest but yeah so let's talk about faze
rug
okay mr problematic you want to give a
little bit of a
yeah explanation he bought a house guys
and then
i reacted to his house great house by
the way
he puts in the title it's a 10 million
dollar house i'm like there's no way
that's a 10 million dollar house there's
no way
so i look it up online sure enough with
a few clicks here and there
you find out he paid 4 million and fifty
thousand dollars in the house
like two months ago and then he claims
it's ten million dollars
not a big deal but i get it it's for the
title
i understand it but he's so going from
four to
two to 10. that's a big leap he
explicitly stated it's a 10 million
dollar house
i've seen other people say something
similar there was a i can't say who it
is but someone else said that they had
like a very expensive home and the home
was really worth like half of that but
face
actually less than half yeah
you know 4.25 and he said it was 10
million
right that's like a big it becomes
easier to half it the more expensive the
home is though
that's what i think like you can't say
you got a million dollar house for 500
grand that's fair
you can't do it but if you have a 30 or
40 million dollar house
you paid 20 for it then maybe it's
arguable yeah maybe it becomes
the line becomes blurry in terms of
value there
yeah i would say i actually have like a
fairly difficult time distinguishing
between like a 50 and 100 million dollar
house
like i could i could see the difference
being like 5 million
or 10 million dollars contrary to 50.
yeah sometimes like that
it's very subjective sometimes but it
also has to do with
sometimes a lot and where the sun rises
up and like what the
view is and how much of that lot is flat
like there's a lot of stuff that goes
into that same with art like art is one
of those very subjective things where to
somebody it might be worth
70 million and for another person will
be worth 130 million dollars so that
could be one of those things
uh-oh i will just leave it we got ramsay
scratching out the window again he wants
he wants out of that window
but that wasn't our only issue with faze
rug do you know what you remember
the other issue i edited it like four or
five times
what was the other issue demonetized oh
how many times oh i re-uploaded it like
the fifth upload
was the one well actually the fourth as
well but we threw in a little edit for
the fifth one
but it got demonetized it got flagged
three times
yeah so it's full screen media so he's
with full screen and they're an mcn so
basically what they do is they comb
the internet for anything that has any
of phases content in it
anything and if there's any match
whatsoever
they will go in and manually just be
like nope that's ours
reclaim the monetization for it it's so
so
basically if you use any of his content
it's not going to get monetized even if
it's in fair use like i would say
that was very much fair use very much
but uh the system
is very much it it's not articulate
enough yet to differentiate between like
what's fair use and what's not
so they err on the side of caution with
that if someone claims your content
most likely they're claiming it for a
reason youtube will side with them and
then it's up to you to prove otherwise
but we're not going to prove otherwise
on a
you know on a reaction video to his
house fortunately enough
if they do claim monetization it's
usually when it's
not published yet so it's still unlisted
so we actually as long as we're ahead
and we can post it and then
you know maybe we're it's going like a
lot uh it's gonna be uploaded
like you guys can all see it like a week
or two from then like we have time to
see if they're gonna claim monetization
so we can remove it re-edit it and then
re-upload it with fixes yeah that's
really one of the best features of
youtube is that you can
uh upload it as unlisted that's what
i've actually been doing now
my new thing is not so much scheduling
i'll leave it unlisted for the first 24
hours
i've always been so superstitious that i
feel like if i
leave a video unlisted and then schedule
it for posting
it somehow impacts the algorithm but
that's that's now not true
i think that was just in my head but uh
yeah so now i leave it unlisted i wait
for a manual review of the video
and then i feel better knowing that like
if someone reviewed the video
and it's good then no problems
whatsoever
yeah you're a little superstitious when
it comes to like youtube algorithms oh
yeah everybody totally like
there have been times where like you'll
want to sit in a specific area
or you want to sit outside or in the
unit like because i've had bad luck
sitting
right there that's my unlucky spot yeah
for uh posting videos it seems like
every time i sit there in a video post
it's bad so the good areas seem to be we
have
so many like ones twos and threes
uh sitting in the by the guesthouse and
not only that like this is exactly where
the pokemane
tragedy happened so that's why i don't
want to sit there
really it's because of that i'm not
going to sit there there's a little
inside gram
right there but yeah that whole phase
rug thing was rough
fortunately we got it all sorted out the
house was incredible
i mean i i really liked it i thought it
was kind of just big just to be big
you know which i think is like a lot of
houses or youtuber houses
i don't think that's that big of a deal
though would you agree they just buy big
houses just because they're big
i think it looks good on camera yeah
it's a set you're buying a studio set is
really what you're doing and
a big house i think has a statement it's
interesting you have more rooms to do
stuff in so i think i think it could be
a good business expense
like imagine if this were double the
size how many
more rooms we would have to film the
podcast yeah
that's very true so that's that's how i
think of it
the most unfortunate thing honestly
about the the getting flagged
is the fact that we have to re-edit it
and to make the video
not what it is like we we have to if you
guys notice we
flip phase rug so it's like inverted
and then we move graham to the other
side and graham is inverted
and then that didn't work so we had to
throw in um
like music over it and then music was
atrocious
if you listen to the music it is most
obnoxious music i don't know what
exactly it's called like an endless pool
an infinity
pool but basically the water just goes
through here i think it's more so the
music we'll
we'll do some testing but i have a
feeling if we could
keep it the way it is but just music
i think it's audio i think youtube will
have an easier time to give audio than
they would visual
stuff it's just unfortunate because
essentially it's the same thing as it
was in the beginning right now it's just
a worse video with
bad music thrown over it yeah but it's
still good content right so like if you
guys haven't seen it yet definitely
check it out smash the like button
exactly and this too yeah yeah smash
like button
so something that's interesting that's
happening right now i i figured we could
try to start talking about this stuff
obviously remaining apolitical just
because you and i aren't
honestly we don't talk politics
whatsoever um
is the the post office thing that's
going on and honestly i'm not i'm gonna
say that i'm a little ignorant when it
comes to this whole situation but i
thought it was interesting to discuss
what i do know and from my understanding
of what's happening is i
think that the democrats proposed
universal mail-in
balloting which essentially means that
they would be sending in ballots via
mail
to like every home or something and then
i think that the the republicans
weren't in favor of that because i think
if more people get
ballots or they send it to like a bigger
group of people or more different types
of people
i think it gives the democrats a
competitive edge and then the
republicans are fighting it
because obviously they don't want the
democrats to win the the election
um and i i think that it's it's very
interesting that
that now we're seeing like what could be
the end of the the post office the usps
you know which is i mean it's been
around for forever
and i think that the thing that i can't
i can't say this
like i don't want to it's too political
do you think i don't know
i think one of their biggest things
though is that um they need to be
accountable for like where all that
money goes and they gotta run them like
a business like there's no reason
why like i get that it's it's a great
service that all of us have to use
no we don't really have to use it but it
but it's a good service
but the reality is that you know my
understanding was there's a lot of
people taking these crazy overtime hours
completely just unsupervised that's
something that
that that is expensive and if it if
we're sending in mail and they're losing
money we should pay more money
you should run it like a business but
technically it is it's a independent
company
that has contracts with the government
yes and
and it's running at a deficit like they
haven't had it's not
been in the green for like thirteen or
four years i don't get it
if they're running in the deficit they
gotta audit their financials figure out
where they're losing money
cut back on those areas or charge more
money yeah i don't think anyone would
complain if the price of a stamp
goes up 15 20 20 i mean it's just
most of us use email it's really only
honestly i don't get even who needs
mail and fedex runs at a profit right
and amazon runs at a profit yeah for
delivering all their stuff yes
i get deliveries okay well i guess what
i'm thinking when i think
mail the first thing that i that comes
to my mind is like you send a postcard
to someone or like we had to send in
some stuff to the city
and it was like why why can't i just
email that to you
take a picture and text it seriously we
should be able to text these they'll be
more organized as well
but yes but let's say package delivery
there should be
a profit they should make money every
time a package gets delivered there
should be no reason why
they need to lose money on packages
that's what i think
so i think it makes sense if they need
to charge more money
they audit their financials they figure
out where they're going wrong
they fix it and then they adjust their
prices accordingly
it doesn't make sense if it's an
independent company that runs for profit
it's not running for profit and it's
being it's being backed and supported by
us
when it's not honestly like my
experiences with the usps have not been
incredible
like whenever i get a delivery and it's
been via usps it has
just been very very poor delivery you
know what
someone there's these numbers don't get
sent out elon musk or someone is going
to come to the rescue and
and it's gonna have drones that's what i
believe like imagine
seriously like imagine you could send
for a drone you have your mail out here
it comes and
picks it up in a basket or something
like that like you just put it in the
basket
and it whizzes off and it goes right to
your destination
uh maybe there's like a sorting facility
or like something there but that's what
i would love something we'll just have
like universal portals
and the portals will just be spread out
and you can throw your stuff in there
and then swipe a wheel that will be like
the destination that you want it to get
sent to
throw it in the portal and it pops out
there that's what elon musk is gonna do
yeah
all right i agree it's gotta be
something like that when do you think
the hyperloop is gonna actually be be
implemented do you think it's gonna
happen for decades
i don't know is it even gonna happen i
hope it does you know what the
i was really upset but the city of i
don't know if it was hawthorne
or inglewood or culver city elon musk
wanted to do
a hyperloop in culver city it was right
by the 405 and the 90 freeway and i was
all excited for that because that's not
too far away
and he wanted to go through like the
bottom of la
and uh they shut it down for some reason
they just it wasn't approved
i don't get it like that that's exciting
stuff that i think would bring so many
jobs
to this city it's it's cool it's it's a
destination
cutting edge it'll it'll help us all out
and the city's like no we don't we don't
want that we don't want
innovation here i don't know i know all
the details i'm sure there's more to it
than just that but still
that's odd but i mean that would be huge
if you guys don't know i'll probably
just throw this in before the hyperloop
is something elon musk is working with
is
his company the boring company
essentially what it is it's like a
vacuum chamber that's underground where
you can like
shoot cars really really fast or
something and you could basically travel
like
ridiculous speeds and since you're in a
vacuum chamber it's like efficient and
it's
quick and it's like a tunnel that you
drive into it's like a train
but for a car you could just drive into
it and like yeah i don't know that's
probably a poor explanation but you guys
get the picture
and uh and yeah i think that it's it's
absolutely incredible
like if you could get that put in that
would be huge i think all across
california you're gonna see property
like
um prices increase and it's one of the
reasons why i've wanted to invest in
if i do get into real estate in a place
like bakersfield because
although it's kind of like a dead zone
right now like not like the greatest
place for for investing in real estate
but if they implement like a hyperloop
or something like that
then all that whole area would probably
like be booming in real estate because
you can live there
and work in la you don't want to live in
bakersfield but you i know it's but it
one of the things is it's just like
proximity wise it's not close to like
any huge
like it's not close to l.a it's not
close to like san fran but you can work
in those places and be living in
bakersfield
yeah maybe hyperloop maybe we'll see so
keep that in mind everybody if they
implement a hyperloop you could invest
in bakersfield maybe you'll see a
pretty awesome you could say five
minutes from the beach
yeah close proximity to the beach
everything yeah let's go on to
life advice from jack and graham got by
the way everyone seems to prefer
jack and graham which really surprised
me i prefer that too
really graham and jack sounds smooth
jack and graham
all right do you have any life advice
just general life advice you could give
the viewers out there
to to have a better life or do you want
me to go first too first
so recently i've been waking up early
and i think that it's
game changing like i'm typically like a
8 30 9 a.m waker
but recently i've been getting up at
like 7 30 which is early for me may not
be early for you guys
and it's huge it is huge so i get start
i can
get started on all of my work early in
the morning i realized
you know if i'm waking up early and like
a little uncomfortable waking up i might
as well put myself to work and it's more
inspiring to work and easier to work
and also i think just that entire day i
feel less lethargic
even if i get less hours of sleep but i
get up early
it works really well and it's inspiring
and you guys should definitely just try
it just try waking up at like 7
7 30 and just see what happens you'll
feel much more energized to get stuff
done
to i don't know to organize your
finances that's what i love doing like
every day in the morning
get get started on the day nice and
early yeah
i would say don't procrastinate that's a
big one there's something you could do
immediately just do it immediately if
you think of it
just go and do it you told me that if
you have chores or you have like a bunch
of stuff to do with a bunch of tasks
the easiest way to attack it is find the
stuff that's going to take three minutes
or less and do that immediately just get
up if you're on the couch just get up
and do it you know you have some dishes
in the sink just get up do it yep
and that's like huge a cluttered
workspace
is also gonna affect your productivity
so if you clean up you do those dishes
you do all that then it's
it's easier to get to work on on a
bigger project exactly
sets off the chain of just you get one
thing done you can get another you get
another you get another
now you have that momentum going for you
can finish anything 100
like once you get started on working and
you started being productive you can't
stop no
it's like a train yeah you're building
momentum exactly that's 100
exactly and it's hard to get that train
going yeah it's at first it's kind of
slow but then once it picks up speed
then it's just unstoppable
that's very true a huge quote in my life
was my cross-country coach said
the hardest part about going for a run
is putting on your shoes and that's
a hundred percent correct the hardest
part isn't the run it's
getting the not the courage but the
getting the courage
yeah you know what i mean like getting
ready to get going and accepting that
you're gonna do it yeah
i agree i've also realized a lot of the
battle in life
is is you against yourself i think it's
important to recognize where you put
your time and where you put your efforts
and to be constantly thinking
what could you be doing to be to be
making making your life better to always
be thinking
what you could be doing what changes you
need to be to make
worded poorly but the concept is there
do you have any other
i have no idea what you just said there
you have no idea no i was like half
zoning out but i was also
listening it's important to know where
you wanna put your efforts
where you wanna what you wanna care
about because in my life it's like
maybe something bad happens right maybe
something bad in my life happens
i can either entertain that whatever bad
experience happened like i can i can let
it affect me
right and i can sit and i can dwell and
i can think about how
unfortunate i am or whatever and i can
put all of this emotion and
like strain into that or i can put
all of that energy into something else
is what i'm trying to say you need to
know where you should yeah i agree and
where you shouldn't care
true like like one thing one of the
biggest things that ever affected me in
my life and i swear to god like it
sounds so stupid but i was coming back
from a soccer tournament with my dad in
the car and i had my feet
up on the windshield and i was totally
slouched in the chair like this
and i had my feet up on the windshield
and i pushed to sit up in the chair
and i broke the windshield whoa i just
completely shattered the windshield
like this this was life-changing for me
yeah and
what happened and my dad was driving and
i was like i was 12 and i was just like
oh my god i just shattered the
windshield and my dad looks at me and he
just goes
oh jack and like that's all he needed to
say
that's all he needed to say and i was
just like i seriously messed up
but the thing that changed me wasn't
really that but it was it was the fact
that
he didn't freak out like he didn't get
angry at me and put all of this
like his rage and like emotion and he
didn't do that
he just he knew that's not something
that he should really care about it's
like i learned my lesson right
and he didn't want to be thinking about
like he didn't want to put all of his
effort into fixing that
you know what i mean are you going to
pay him back for that
i was like 12. now i was really like
i was in fifth grade it's like i learned
my lesson right and i felt terrible and
i still do
maybe someday i'll bam back but like
that concept is what i'm trying to apply
here
it's like he didn't want to waste all of
that that strain in that that
that i get it now daily bottled energy
he didn't want to waste 20
of that just being frustrated i agree
with that yeah which i think is huge
i agree with that that's a good point
one of the most transformative
experiences in my life and i haven't
talked about it
to him literally since the incident but
i always think about that should bring
him on the podcast
just bring him on the podcast tell them
about that seriously oh
i mean he'll he'll see this that one
turned off okay
that was a good story thank you i it's
sometimes it's hard for me to word stuff
but that's essentially what i was trying
to tell it's just interesting to me what
sticks out to you and what doesn't yeah
you know it seems like such a small
event in my life but it really
really i mean breaking a car windshield
i've never done that before
with your feet when you're just dead no
never such a small thing but yeah
i don't think it's a small thing
breaking a car but like like i'm saying
like i'm just in the car with my dad
coming back from a soccer tournament
how many times in my life a million
times and i just try to sit up yeah but
you only broke the windshield
once that's a member of your point
that's very if anyone broke a windshield
they would remember it yeah
yeah but there you guys go i think it's
important to know where you should put
your care into and what you shouldn't
yeah
do you have any other advice uh oh
there's ramsay
ramsay has some advice hello ramsay hey
i don't know
i'm not good with coming up with advice
on the spot this early
you're gonna lay down
ramsay oh oh good oh there we go
he's gonna just he's gonna join us i
wish ramsay was in frame
for anyone who doesn't see this here you
go here's ramsay
there's uh there's us ramsay
hey there he is oh
oh my gosh so that's what we're looking
at now
my final piece of advice is to think
long term
and think about your decisions now how
they affect you short term and how they
affect you long term
and to always put preference into the
long term yeah
that's it's the most important thing i
agree and to
like if you aren't investing now start
investing now because
although it might be difficult now when
you're 50
when you're 60 you're gonna be so
grateful that you did
so grateful yep and get your two free
stocks
down below in the description because
when you deposit a hundred dollars
fourteen hundred
one thousand you're gonna oh you know
what that's one of those things you
should not procrastinate
on that if you're thinking about doing
it do it now
graham i have not done it are you
serious
no you're messing with me are you
serious
i haven't done it why because it takes
like an hour no it doesn't take an
hour are you serious maybe five or six
minutes tell me
how how did that affect you the fact
that i said i haven't done it you really
i don't i think you're joking
i'm not why it
it takes like five minutes to open up an
account
type in your info yeah all you got you
link your bank account there you send
over 100 bucks
and within like a few days you end up
getting two stocks
yeah i haven't done it come on let's do
it right really yeah let's just see what
two free stocks i get
they're not going to show up immediately
that's the thing i wish you could just
sign up within seconds you get to
it takes it takes like a day or two
for them to go and verify your account
and then for the deposit to go through
you got to use the the link the
affiliate link okay
here so let's go to graham stefan
stock marketplace
oh grim said that took him like seven
takes yeah what's up guys you it's here
graham now i could say it
yeah you could i could you know okay all
right you better do it right afterwards
though
have you ever seen the tv show how i met
your mother uh
a few episodes here and there why
there's a concept in the show
where you find someone you think that
they're great you think that they're
amazing you don't you see
little faults but you don't see any
reason why anyone could ever hate this
person right
and then all of a sudden you have this
this epiphany it's called like the plate
crash
right and it's they played a plate crash
sound every single time this happened in
the show
and essentially what that is is like
you're like oh
i get why people could dislike this
person oh i see this
huge fault in them yeah was that weeble
the plate crash for you
get out get over it get out
yeah oh man i thought you were dry come
on why wouldn't you have done it
dude i because every time i open up an
account with a brokerage it takes like
an hour like i was doing it
oh no it doesn't i was doing it for my
friend
we've i've opened up accounts like
full-on bank accounts in like
five minutes yeah but that's another
thing to remember a password too and a
username too and
could i try some of your coffee yeah
sure i wanna because you say it's better
isn't it i'm trying some coffee from
meet kevin because he gave graham the
free
coffee maker graham says it's a big
change from the mr coffee coffee maker
which i now own thank you graham
that is stronger yep and ramsay did not
move
no good job ramsay there you go oh do
you think that the
the money advice you give other people
is different than the money advice
you have for yourself or what you
practice
oh really um because now because now
it's just
my income has gone up so much so if i
spend something
uh it's just it's such a small
percentage
based on everything else i mean that
that's the thing it's like if someone
spent
ten dollars on you know on a vacation or
whatever you would you wouldn't even bat
an eye
um but if i spent a thousand dollars it
would be like this the the equivalent of
someone else spending ten so
um i would say overall it's pretty much
i rarely spend money anyway
rarely i mean we went to chipotle last
night that was like sixteen dollars
yeah that was that was my entire
spending basically for the day was 16
bucks
so overall no graham and i have these
cute little dates
usually about once a week oh yeah once a
week uh jack and i will work late
and then we go to dinner that's been our
thing yeah
so this time we had chipotle last time
we also had chipotle
i think the time for that it's usually
chipotle and we both get the same thing
but like 16 bucks
16 a week ain't bad that's not bad no
and it's a business write-off
yeah we talk business exactly it's for
that's like eight dollars business use
yeah exactly eight dollars after tax
so that's not bad it's worth it for a
good meal
good meal good meal good talk good
bonding
cute date i find that the advice i give
other people is
oftentimes more risky than the advice i
what i practice
i tell other people that they should
basically invest everything except an
emergency fund at least at my age
into index funds but for me i've built
up a savings
and now i have like a legit savings that
i do not invest into
index funds or mutual funds because i'm
i'm content
with like my current investing when i in
reality
real estate i should be investing more
because i don't honestly have that i
keep telling you to invest more money
had you invested a few weeks ago i mean
you would be up like five
percent on your money everything has
gone up
check the markets now i've been telling
you just to invest it all in
let's see let's see how much i would
have yes up today
wow look at that i was down like six
grand on the uh
my stocks earlier today and now i'm up 4
800.
what a difference i'm glad every morning
i wake up and i buy more
uh schb and charles schwab
and uh yeah i bought it literally at the
low today but i i tried
i had fun every day trying to like time
i could time the market within a day as
long as i'm investing
it's not that big of a deal but uh yeah
that 50 grand that you invested in that
one video is it up or down since you
invested in it
it's up how much 80 33 okay so i'm not
up that much 80 33
okay so i'm up 125 dollars 100 so
aka less than the amount i'm up on
options
yeah but that's just one time i bought
and bought i've been buying like every
day i know i just i love
your time all right yeah but yeah it's
not meaning that the advice i give other
people is bad because i give them more
like liberal advice with their money is
that's not the case
it's just that for some reason people
are just risk-averse
that's at least in my experience i'm
very risk-averse so i'm very very very
concerned with his mind you shouldn't be
you shouldn't be
i know i shouldn't be no i should really
be
i should max out my 2020 roth ira yeah
today
ah it's another thing that's not going
to take you very long with it just do it
i know it's not going to take me long no
but i maxed out my 2019 when like i'm
like
what three yeah good to go and max it
out this year
yeah the sooner you invest the better i
should be dollar cost averaging
no you don't use a dollar cost average
for what just to to make sure
that everything is going according to
plan you're going to be making money
every single month if you dump in what
you have right now you're going to have
more money next month
more money the month after more money
you're going to end up dollar cost
averaging
anyway what do you say four thousand a
month
five thousand a month i should be
investing is that good yeah you'd be
happy yes
all right deal i'll do that cool four or
five thousand a month here you've got
this one four or five four four thousand
dollars fine because you're gonna have
to pay taxes and whatnot so the other
stuff for robin hood
uh selling puts options trading okay
fine
[Laughter]
i'll keep my bases of three grand so i
thought it would be a funny idea
jack uh single and he's ready to mingle
and so he made a tinder account so if
you're in the
what what's your radius like a 100 mile
radius um i would say
500 miles if you will personally buy
your plane ticket i'll put you up in a
hotel yeah if you're within a 50-mile
radius
of like los angeles i would say and
uh you set your age to like 21 to 23.
jack is gonna show up like if you swipe
enough i'll show up
you'll show up on on the account so
anyway jack has been swiping and i
thought it would be
really funny to basically have jack's
first tinder date
on the podcast so what would you like
you wouldn't even have
met this person before yeah but just you
would have matched
and say like hey have for the first date
come on the podcast
and we just have a tinder date on the
podcast for the first time
i think that would be amazing that would
be so much fun you would officiate
it'd be me and this this yeah poor lady
let's be realistic that is not the most
ideal for his date mean this poor lady
yeah
and it would yeah it takes like this
person would have to be so
confident to be willing to be on camera
to come on a podcast like
already we're going to weed out 90 of
people out there
because i don't i don't even think i
would have been comfortable with doing
something i wouldn't
like i don't want to be like filmed with
strangers and then be
grilled from the podcast so they could
be
on chipotle yeah yeah exactly what
credit score yeah that's something too
you tell your tinder
like please bring your bank statements
so we can ridicule you in front of us
but here's the thing if someone does
agree
to to come on the podcast you know
they're they're a sport yeah they'd be
up for anything like that's an
adventurous person
who's willing to try new things put
themself out of their comfort zone
those are all really great qualities to
have but at that same time like i want
someone to come on the podcast from me
you know what i mean it's like i won't
they would be doing it for for you i
don't think would they be doing it for
that for the podcast or like
the pod get what 10 000 views yeah no
but like maybe they thought it was
bigger
i don't know you're gonna look you're
gonna do research yeah
probably whoever's gonna maybe they're
gonna be watching this vid how about
this too
if uh tell people what you what you're
looking for in a girl what do you
what do you want and if there's someone
watching this right now who wants to
come on the podcast
in la all you need to do is just dm jack
on instagram
say saw your podcast i want to be on it
or something like that here's some info
about me
yeah um what what's your age bracket you
like like
what do you want um
legal consenting age so what we're going
to say 18 to 25
18 to 25 female i'm just gonna say this
for you 18 25 female
um like what likes
likes hiking yeah likes being outdoors
likes running
maybe into personal finances ramsay stop
it likes personal finance to some degree
uh like saving money i really am not
picky
yeah no standards at all no standards
really
has to be alive and yeah i'll take it it
has to be
yeah it has to have a heartbeat alive
yeah okay that's gotta be a lie it's
stretching at the moment
yeah so that's essentially our current
status i made it the top line of my
tinder bio
that i have serious inquiries only
looking for someone to come on the
podcast
no one wants to do it i've like i've
matched with people i said hey you want
to come on the podcast like i'm really
trying to get
the segment for a podcast would anyone
like to they're like no
i don't want to be on a podcast how many
people did you get to the point where
you brought that up though
four they all said no four said no
all said no yeah they don't want to do
it dude it's a lot
it's a lot to ask of somebody there was
a girl
that i that i matched with and then she
she messaged me first and she said
like i know graham stefan reference when
i see one
because in my bio it says like iced
coffee hour with graham
and then and then i was like oh do you
because i don't think she was aware of
the podcast
yeah i was like do you know of it and
she's like yeah she's like i like him do
you like him i'm like yeah
and then i was like and then we were
talking like about stuff and i was like
i dropped out of ucsb to work with him
she goes to ucsb
and i said do you want to come on the
podcast and she was like what
you can't tell me you actually actually
work with graham like she didn't connect
the dots that we work together and then
i told her and then she freaked out
and uh she's not here and i thought she
was going to be here today
i thought she was going to show up jesse
wait what
there's a girl the girl that was the one
yeah she got back to you
she didn't get back to me no she was
like she was super excited when she
learned that we worked together and then
she didn't respond
i don't know the ladies are confusing
like
here's the deal right yeah and you tried
too can we say what you did on your
instagram
oh i mean let's not go into too much
i i put out a feeler to see if we can
get someone for the podcast for jack
and uh yeah different uh
different demographic different people
our interests
gender of people responded than what we
it's like it was like a ten to two yeah
it's a comment i'm very
humbled yeah but i
i have a preference did you message the
one that i sent you to send her a
message or no you didn't do it okay
did okay no it didn't i don't know okay
i have a preference
of women and just making that clear
okay um uh
moving on yeah one thing that's
incredible
if we continue on our current trajectory
with the second channel
this could be the first ever 40k month
yeah 40 and we just had our first 30k
month yeah
no it wasn't the first 30 came up yes it
was no yeah it was
may no no may that was our first 30k
month no
yes it was really i think so if i'm
remembering i think so i didn't research
this but if i remember correctly
it was our first ever 30 000 right
income month for the second channel and
we're gonna hit 40 000
maybe we probably realistically won't
yeah but
because cpm's went a little bit down
yeah that's true but
yeah we could be hit like i mean 40k
month is definitely in the foreseeable
future for the second channel
which is pretty cool yeah like
absolutely massive
that video just posted that uh we did a
first
ever uh reddit review reddit review
i think i think i have a good feeling
about reddit i don't know i just i
i gotta i got a good feeling about it i
rarely get
good feelings about stuff like this but
when i do
i think this is the new big thing i
think is going to be reddit reviews like
this
intuition yeah but that's that's
literally little news stories yeah the
thing about youtube
the thing about any like community where
you get contributions from a ton of
people like
youtube everyone can post um anything
like that i think is
really really successful
ramsay come on get down
i don't know ramsay
down what are you doing up there good
boy
get down
the thing about any community like that
where you have so many people
contributing
i think since you have so much
information and
like i said so many people contributing
you have that much more of a chance
to hit something and to to get something
that will spark people's interests
and i think that's what's great about
reddit is like you have so many people
posting stuff and so many people liking
stuff
that literally the best of the best gets
to the top the best of the best
gets upvoted the best of the best gets
to be seen by you whereas something like
cnbc
how many how many people contributing do
they have writing those articles
a lot they have a lot but think about
reddit how many people they have like
two million
people in the wall street that's
community what i like about reddit
though is that people can upvote what
they want to see more of
and things like cnbc or cnn or or any of
those news sites
they choose to place which ones
generally are the most popular
i don't know if they have control over
the trending they probably have a good
idea of which ones people are clicking
on i find them to be pretty accurate for
their like top 5 trending
on cnbc but you know for the most part
reddit is is so organic and it changes
like every hour there's something new on
there
it's true to what people are interested
in yeah it's not
like like figured out already what's
going to be at the top what's
not going to be exactly so it's good
yeah reddit is a definitely a gold mine
i think that video is going to do well
if it doesn't
i think that we will do more like it
yeah one more
minute and we'll figure out what it is
out of attendance exactly
a lot of it does have to do with
thumbnail and title though because this
video we've never done anything like it
so people may be
unfamiliar yeah with what we're doing in
the video i agree i'm curious to see
what this is going to be out of a 10
uh because right now we're at uh almost
5 000 views
but let's see if it climbs because right
now what happens is you get a big
surge of views then it dips down and
then it goes back up so that
back up is that average view duration
yeah very important for that swing
backup
yeah but yeah we're still trying to
figure out the best way that we can
scale the second channel and i think
having more variable content is very
important so if we throw in stuff like
the reddit reviews
huge for the channel and if we can do
the mori
if we can do the dr phil oh man yeah
that's gotta happen at some point
like that is a it could be like a
mainstream media type production
yeah you show up you have your own
little space
people fight it out and you solve the
money and marital issues
we need i feel like like a live studio
audience and stuff like that at some
point
like a full-on studio yeah where
like it's professional like it looks
like dr phil where i'm in a high chair
like that
and there's other people in high chairs
and you know
they just give over the bank statements
you're gonna have like a designated
place
like unlike the ranch that you can send
them to
send them to the bank go to the yeah go
to the bank
like some place you can send the badge
oh my yeah
i would love that and then for the
audience to be like listen good news
guys
as a thank you uh weeble is giving
everyone a
free stock and just people are just like
everyone from happiness
not only run you like what 18 bucks yeah
that would be hilarious and then be like
one of the audience members gets a free
fang stock
yeah what whoa
yeah i think that's great because like
colin and samir said they had
amazing advice like they said it's
really good when they
as an audience can experience something
that you're experiencing at the same
time
because when they see you learning and
growing rather than just regurgitating
researched information
yeah then it gives them a good idea of
who you really are you know because if
you're
learning something you really show your
character in that at that point in time
and i think that that would be really
really interesting that's true
throw some wild cards at you and just
see how you react it's kind of what the
phone calls are but also it's not
because it's not in person it's like
it's different yeah but if we could come
up with something like that i mean that
would be
amazing that would be fun we got to do
that we're looking at craigslist ads
we were thinking about doing it but
realistic we'd have to pay them yeah
like a hundred dollars a person probably
i don't think we're there yet it's it's
a big investment for something we don't
know how it's going to do
also during the trust yeah we got to try
on a small scale yeah
yeah but that would be really really
interesting and let us know if you guys
would
ever be interested in seeing something
like that i think the answer to that is
going to be a yes but
let's see yeah what do you think this is
out of the 10 it's eight
five that's not bad five out of ten five
out of ten
seven dislikes who dislikes that video
the commentary everything was spot on
you guys haven't seen that that's a
funny video
this guy this guy funny guy funny guy
we're basically done i'm just gonna
throw up well we got one google question
that i liked
hey guys my name's jack rackham i
recently made the jump into working
full-time on youtube and i'm curious to
know if there's been a point on any of
your channels that you had to make a
serious pivot when did you know it was
the right time and how do you weigh the
importance of consistency
against doing the same thing over and
over expecting different results
serious pivot the main channel has
really been
for the most part almost the same the
serious pivot i guess for me
if there was any was once i started
getting more views i started taking it
really seriously i'm like i can't mess
this up
so i just i doubled down i made better
content i put
more thought in my titles and thumbnails
really tried to make every video as
great as possible
it took about a year for me really to
start getting good at that
um second channel was was a major pivot
for me just
doing something different but other than
that i've been really good at just doing
the same thing
consistently you did make a pivot though
in
in obviously the format and your video
just like content because you did you
know you had like a car review
you had like the mcdonald's thing it was
about a year
it was about a year for me to start
dialing in yeah because then i was
figuring out what people wanted to see
more of and i had a good idea of what
people like
what people didn't like what i liked
doing what people wanted to see what got
pushed on youtube so i had to
say about it took about a year of just
practice
one thing people don't realize i think i
mean i'm very i'm not a youtube creator
but like i think that people
don't take they don't treat it like a
business no
and it's making money like a business
they don't treat it like it's a it's a
job
a lot of youtube creators and it very
very well could be or
is a job for people like titling and
thumbnailing
is that's it's art wow it really is it's
paramount if you're going to be a good
creator and you want to get views you
want to get clicks
that is so crucial yeah i mean we spend
hours titling and thumbnailing every
sometimes that's my least favorite part
of the video is title and thumbnail
because sometimes i know it's like the
video topic itself is
awesome i'm really happy about it but
then it's like it does the title and
thumbnail are so important
that i'm like oh that's this that can be
the hardest thing because everything
rides on that yeah like
everything is on the title thumbnail but
that's about when you pivoted a year in
when you realized you could make a lot
of money
right mm-hmm yeah it was about 100 000
subscribers was when i started
started really dialing it in what were
you making back then 100k subscribers
uh two grand a month
two grand a month about that maybe three
two to three so job yeah
i think i mean some months where like
five other months were
two so it fluctuated i think one month
was like 32.
so about that
that's what was that hailed the coffee
oh man so thanks jack rackham by the way
nice youtube channel great he's got like
a hundred thousand subscribers
nice yeah let's make some really
interesting content i'll check it out
yeah then we have just a couple money
questions that i threw in just as bonus
questions
what's your credit score uh right now
about seven
seven seventy or so seven seven yeah
mine is like
740 or 730 i've had
one line of credit for well over a year
now
and i pay it off in full i keep my
utilization fairly low my average
utilization is probably about 15
10 but it really like
as soon as i opened it up i think my
score was like 700
and it's gone up 40 points in over a
year that seems
slow to me and i've i've huffered around
735 740
for probably six months yeah it's just
time
give it more time if you give that
another year you'll be fine
length of credit history it really
doesn't matter if you have a score
between like
750 and 850. no no difference
really i would say 760 then people start
like treating you
giving you credits stuff like that but
you're not gonna your rate's not really
gonna differ that much above 750.
in the zoom call mentorship group link
down below yeah
um i was talking to a member and he says
that he
invests in like michigan or something
and he's
never visited there but he has like
three or four rental properties
and what he does he lives here in l.a
what he does is he finds
an agent that will also be a property
manager and since
they're going to be the property manager
to that property then they're going to
find
listings that are going to be easy to
manage like not in a crummy neighborhood
they're very familiar with the area they
know the market well
and then he just buys the house and then
they
they'll buy it for him and then they'll
also manage the property and he says
his returns are crazy what if they're a
bad manager it seems like he's got he's
been really fortunate so far he has been
fortunate i think he's used the same
person
good um and he probably shopped around
and he talked to a lot of agents and
stuff like that maybe the ones that
didn't flake or anything
but he's like he can get like easily
over 10 return easily over
10. yeah and the property's there like
40 000
wow so i'm considering trying something
out like that because realistically
if i put a down payment for like i don't
know talk to brandon
investmentjoy yeah he'd be a good one
yeah he's buying all these properties
that's 20 30 and i can i know for a fact
i can trust brandon
right yeah yeah i would probably go with
him
i think that might be pretty interesting
to sell houses doesn't he he has his
license does i think he has his lice i'm
not sure but he buys a lot
yeah but realistically if he's gonna buy
from me might as well just buy for
himself
maybe but i'm sure he could throw you a
deal i mean how many deals can the guy
possibly buy
right he has like trailer parks yeah
exactly so
i'm sure there's one or two that he just
no
we'll pass off maybe i don't know so
we're basically done
uh i think it'd be interesting if we
could just throw in
some recommendations of the week so do
you have a song recommendation for the
viewers of the week
song recommendation i have man
i don't know song recommendation let's
uh
how about sweetness by jimmy eat world
sweetness by jimmy eat world i have to
listen to that i don't think i've heard
that
um all right so check that out guys my
song recommendation of the week
pluto projector by rex orange county
check those out let us know what you
think about that is there any other
recommendations movie recommendations tv
show recommendations
i started watching dexter so oh my wait
did you just start it yeah
yes i was literally gonna recommend
actually i was gonna say yeah yeah
yeah no i just started it started like
the other week
it's good yes i really like it so far i
mean the character dexter is
amazing i just finished dexter it's
incredible oh cool
check that out guys thank you so much
for watching
really appreciate it make sure to uh get
your two free stocks down below in the
description hit the like button
subscribe button notification
bell add us on instagram and uh
pretty much daily so if you want to be a
part of it there feel free to feel free
to add us
yeah and uh uh tinder dates for jack let
us know in the description or if you
are yourself a a possible candidate for
a date on the podcast just
dm jack and uh we'll be in touch single
ladies only please
no married ladies please so with that
study guys thank you so much for
watching
and until next time
another thing that's really cool is
oh yeah do you want to explain the do we
want to mention
why would we not we're not going to
mention until we have more information
about it yes okay
is this the 14th 14th ever
right she never got back to me by the
way
oh really yeah well she probably just
didn't see it yeah
maybe do you have read receipts turned
on i don't know
oh i thought if you pay for the
expensive one it tells you if they read
your message or not we don't want people
knowing i pay for the expensive one
okay when you're desperate enough to pay
for it they know